alors bon
merci de
aujourd'hui alors il faut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui les films ou les vidéos
en général c'est vachement ça fait une
grande partie dans notre société que ce
soit un challenge artistique pour
transmettre des émotions ou partager un
message mais c'est aussi des enjeux
financiers car ça permet de vendre des
produits et des services
créer innover c'est devenu vachement
important dans ce domaine car ça permet
de vous être reconnus ou tout simplement
de montrer ce qu'on vient de faire et
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de vous parler de
la petite révolution liée aux mouvements
de la caméra et comment on en est amené
à utiliser des jouets des drones fpv
pour des productions vidéo est alors
pour voir un bonbon très rapidement ce
qui est possible de faire
je vais vous montrer ça
[Musique]
alors un drone spv c'est plutôt simple
c'est un châssis en carbone avec des
hélices des moteurs une batterie un
émetteur récepteur une carte de vol une
caméra mais il ya quelquefois un peu de
colle chaude alors il faut savoir qu'un
drone de ce type ça coûte environ 200 à
300 euros
et ce qui est bien avec ça c'est que ça
coûte pas cher du coup on a tendance à
quand même vite les cracher comme vous
avez pu le voir alors ça se pilote avec
une radiocommande de ce type et on voit
en direct ce que le drone voix grâce à
une petite caméra et ses lunettes de
retransmission vidéo
parfois on ressemble un peu à un alien
camp mais ça alors ça c'est ce qu'on
appelle le fpv ou first person who ou le
vol en immersion
il faut savoir que le drone fpv il a été
popularisé en france mais ça on va y
revenir plus tard d'abord ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que les multi rotor où les
drones comme on les connaît maintenant
ça fait seulement dix ans que ça existe
et seulement 5 ou c'est fiable à
l'origine c'est une manette de wii qui a
été démonté à quai où on a récupéré le
capteur de position et on a branché tout
ça une arduino nous clairement sa volée
mais c'était quand même pas glorieux
mais grâce à la passion d'une dizaine de
personnes ils ont pu faire évoluer le
code de vols pour permettre un
comportement de vol constant qui a
permis la commercialisation des
premières pièces à partir de là on a eu
deux grandes familles qui se sont créés
on a les drones type caméra volante que
vous devez sûrement connaître
et puis les drones de modélistes qui
étaient là un peu comme les avions versé
ou les planeurs rcsq ont piloté avec une
radiocommande est en vue en les voyant
alors il faut savoir que leader du
marché actuel il n'avait pas encore
sorti leur premier drone et tout ça là
dedans
les drones comme on les connaît
maintenant les drones de modélisme
c'était seulement un peu une idée
farfelue qu'on avait dans la tête et la
commercialisation de ses premières
classes c'était un peu compliqué car
c'était vraiment un marché très petit
marché où seuls les hardcore orly a
doctor prenez du plaisir à bricoler ces
machines alors je faisais partie de ceux
là est clairement après avoir galéré
pendant mes études et surtout pendant
mes concours d'écoles en entrée d'entrée
en écoles d'ingénieurs
je passais mon temps sur ses forums à
essayer de trouver le meilleur code le
meilleur composants pour faire voler ses
fichiers drones alors oui le drone a
volé et oui j'ai coupé mes concours
d'entrée en écoles d'ingénieurs
alors après avoir raté mais mes concours
je me suis et surtout bien avant ça je
me suis toujours fait la promesse de
pain parce qu'ils allaient ex que ce
soit le boulot ou les études j'avais
quand même toujours continuer le
modélisme parce que le modélisme ça m'a
apporté tellement de choses ça m'a
apporté des compétences mais surtout ça
m'a fait rencontrer des personnes est
clairement à cette époque là je voyais
pas pourquoi je devrais arrêter le
modélisme n'importe que ça devait être
alors après avoir loupé du coup mais les
concours j'ai quand même chercher un iut
et c'est tivité pour les chercher
j'avais des critères assez spécifique
il fallait absolument qui est un club de
modélisme à côté et en parcourant mais
les forums des métiers rotor il y en
avait toujours un qui revenait et ce
club là c'est ergonet les airs gonesse
et à 5 minutes 10 6 et argonnais dans
une forêt lieu leur truc
leur truc à eux c'était le vol en
immersion il mettait des petites caméras
et on voyait en direct ce que la caméra
voyait sur un écran et moi j'ai toujours
eu un peu ce rêve utopique de pouvoir me
mettre à la place de mes modèles réduits
ce soit des avions des planeurs voire
même des voitures et eux ils ont poussé
le truc encore plus loin car il se tirer
la bourre façon course de podracer de
star wars
alors c'était vraiment incroyable de
voir ça de l'extérieur parce que il
secourt est l'un derrière l'autre à fond
à travers la forêt avec des lumières et
ça ça se crashait c'était vraiment
génial à voir
et d'ailleurs j'ai vraiment pas mis
longtemps à m'y mettre aussi après ça on
n'a pas mis longtemps aussi à vouloir
partager cette émotion ce qu'on vivait à
travers ces petites machines
alors après plusieurs vidéos sur youtube
il y en a vraiment d'eux qu'ils ont
vraiment pesé
on parle de 5 millions de vues sur
youtube des articles dans les journaux
des interviews avec des chaînes de télé
il y avait même des entreprises qui
venaient nous voir pour nous demander
des conseils
après ça on a vraiment vu c'est vraiment
ici à annecy à cinq minutes de cette
éviter que cette discipline a été
popularisé et c'est à partir de là qu'on
savait que un drone fpv c'était à peu
près cette taille là sa demande est à
peu près certains composants et surtout
on savait ce que c'était maintenant et
je rappelle c'était même pas cinq
minutes de cet iut
alors on a bien vu la communauté évolué
on a vu aussi le matériel évolué et au
cours d'une année où c'était vraiment le
début à chaque fois qu'on change et une
hélice un moteur ou simplement le code
sur notre carte de vol les drones de
vienne est plus précis plus fun surtout
beaucoup plus rapide et à partir de là
il ya le domaine de la compétition qui a
paru à la compétition ces drones sont
devenus des vraies machines de course
on parle de 0 à 100 km heure en moins
d'une demi seconde
juste pour vous donner un peu et un
ordre d'idée c'est trois fois plus
rapide qu'un dragster américains les
plus gros là vraiment gros
et d'ailleurs avec cette compétition
c'est venu l'évolution des pilotes
comment les pilotes volet avec sa
machine et quand c'est vraiment bien
fait les lignes elles sont d'une
fluidité mais parfaite
c'est à dire qu'on va passer dans des
petits trous des petits obstacles qu'on
va mettre un peu partout sur un terrain
est vraiment la ligne à sera super
fluide et c'est vraiment cette recherche
de fluidité qui nous intéresse en tant
que pilote
d'ailleurs on n'a pas mis longtemps avec
quelques pilotes et moi même
mettre des go pro sur ces drones donc un
peu comme celui là vous voyez
aujourd'hui et c'est vraiment la vidéo
c'est devenu le sujet de la vidéo
c'était devenu le vol de ce drone et
puis ce drone là c'est devenu un outil
pour transmettre des émotions capturer
des performances la performance du vol
elle est maintenant au service de
l'image pour la compléter et la faire
évoluer
d'ailleurs vous pouvez retrouver mes
images et certaines de mes collègues
dans des campagnes publicitaires des
clips de rap et même maintenant des
films de voyage en faisant ça ce qui est
ce qu'on ne vient de faire la
maintenance et ceux de révolutionner un
peu le mouvement de la caméra
parce que cette caméra maintenant on est
possible de la mettre où on veut avec
vitesse agilité et fluidité
ce qui était un peu un rêve pour un
réalisateur vidéo
c'est maintenant possible pour notre
grâce à notre passion pour déjouer
ça reste des jouets ça pèse autour de
500 à 600 grammes c'est presque autant
qu'un ballon de foot c'est un jouet et
grâce à ça ce qu'on peut retenir de tout
ça c'est ce qui était un peu une
promesse naïve et enfantine que j'ai eue
de ne pas arrêter le modélisme s'est
retrouvé pertinente mais quinze ans plus
tard c'est cette sensation c'est cette
capacité à retransmettre la sensation du
vol par exemple à une à une société de
création de jeux vidéo ou tout
simplement à imager la connexion entre
un rider et son vélo de lors d'une
descente dans la forêt tout ça
aujourd'hui c'est mon métier maintenant
ce que j'ai envie de toujours à pied
c'est que ne lâchez pas vos passions
mais plutôt de devenir bon là dedans et
devenez très bon et poussé le truc de
plus en plus loin car aujourd'hui
personne ne connaît votre métier dans
cinq ans merci
[Applaudissements]